testing testing
you
what's going on you guys it's gonna be
an event we're gonna love this we're
gonna love it man we're gonna love it I
don't think they can hear you I saw it I
saw desktop of all you oh I'm listening
to the music still so
you
all right we'll be we'll be here
momentarily
we're waiting for the game we're waiting
for the king kids moved by jumping we
don't know yet but I will
you
going up actually let's just do the old
Google hangout because this is uh we
don't need the the Iron Horse podcast
thing what's up you guys
we here at exceed can show ya in trouble
somebody thought I wasn't ahead of same
energy to boys up flag is out that's
about to be on the ground amber so for a
mouth dope talking regulates flapping
their gums though a reaction yes looking
for some I heard somebody gums is busted
for a while you ain't been acting me for
a minute my Twitter being what box Sonia
really is about to come out here gonna
be a magician magician is out here flip
flop numbers you know what you do where
you team we can do 25 hold your head boy
look who's your head boy we're eat we
bust your narrative right in the mouth
we already took your sauces mixture
sauce around your neck in myself Ernie
you just be quicker you three seconds
quicker that's nice I heard you gotta
drop one of them BAE's you gonna pull up
with them flaps flaps
we got flaps
[Music]
you're doing the flops doing H ones on
you PlayStation sir Sir you don't know
that is the series XE supposed to be
fighting he playing irregular I got the
wrong type of a vilius Lord box problems
with these flaps study go now some
pre-orders you know the fire Lord tipsy
you don't fire scream oh wow
Cyrus Burke thank you brother filed a
super check I have a court order so
facade by Supreme Court judge and if the
ps5 is more powerful King has to buy us
both next-gen consoles
plus extra storage if it's not I want
all those knees in the box and I want
your money though what's your cash to
you ain't getting Sunday King this ain't
Sunday bro you Fred to the row so we
gotta get you in with it's been a minute
you never bet on the show so let me know
suppose what you're supposedly Xbox mine
announcer studio today I don't think I
don't think feel worried about this at
all but we bout to see before we see the
fatigue on xbox a Xbox has 16 studio
yeah
I'm here in annum here and I think it's
absolute studio the people will make a
plate oh oh yeah mm-hmm I think it's
them thank you also you have to remember
they got that game Stax live later sup
they set them up already
bully go get you let's get screaming Oh
[Laughter]
can't wait for these stats oh I get back
to clamp slamming in this quarantine
stay clam slamming hello yeah careful
out there clam slamming make sure don't
come with a golf grips Wow stitch he's
spitting King bars that's right but I
see their energy for that not teraflops
he said that drug is delicious delicious
as he did it goes up and around email
everybody else are ready for this soon
soon it's all cool cuz I'm screen I
don't get it you get the ghosts no say
they had a ghost in a minute tradução
some new faces fresh faces you know say
filed a bikini
that's my man let's go the good thing
about this is I don't matter how many
people were here it ends when it ends
and when you bring on a bicycle and they
bring out a bicycle I'm ending
vehicle the graphic god GG the sony
scooter slow Lord I can always see
whatever giving a whole strong eight
they give you a body breaking snap these
spine with a bob backlund eight four
talk about it go be funny that's what I
said we're gonna be upset we're gonna
look right at them because they got a
bob backlund eight a forte
what are you even doing right now
Forte's on quarantine unfortunately my
my work don't care about no corn gee I'm
still out here in these streets I'm
looking at people look what's up man you
got that stuff when teraflops confirmed
let's go no he said there's no car read
the king o means you see when you turn
it on you input your credit card number
right now
would you tear flunk Kingo he go turn
his camera he gonna say 13 that's when
that magician man before the last time
with the PlayStation Pro Oh Christopher
ha is in here Chris this is gonna be the
fastest turnaround you ever did your
life 15 minutes screaming a building
he's literally Twitter he's going to
lead his accountant oh hello there you
go screaming is debut ask you real quick
squeeze I've never had you on before we
know you from PC Fame so just curious if
any of these consoles you know got you
excited I I'm very curious to see what
is there today I you know I'm sort of I
think a lot of it is gonna come down to
I mean hardware I think it's gonna be
important but I think aesthetically
there's going to be a
people don't think that's important it
is a lot of people won't buy something I
want it statically be put in their house
a lot of people do it's made beautiful
look yeah I saw it when it come down
Oh stick is for you stitched for you you
made that for you check her discord whoo
my disco not you guys I've never asked
you to check your disco okay roll low
with the sleep eyes Spencer's on this
date announces that Scarlett is powerful
[Music]
new games crazy trucks they own the
warehouse that supplies the stores so
that's where I go so before I get to
your uh Nantucket so whatever I got you
got it already so you would say as a PC
gamer you know I'm saying our statics
yeah we'll talk talk to me of these
consoles is exciting
yeah I mean I think a lot of its gonna
come down to I mean would any of them
deter me from like building a PC oh
that's like the question for me is like
I think it'll be the question for quite
honestly you've been very vocal how bad
your PC is come over to the Xbox does
does the series X reveal the technical
reveal did you catch that yesterday I
watched a private review on it actually
like a guy some somebody got their hands
on they read oh listen Steve Austin it
might have been yes oh yeah
sometimes I just type it in I don't know
exactly who they do tech reviews all the
time but I don't know probably awesome
it's probably awesome you very hardware
in there I think you did a really good
job that also did a really good job did
a good job you know but I'm biased with
my old team man you got 40 of its most
powerful listen man I want this to be
honest with you
they've been saying the most fastest
most powerful Xbox all right you have to
look at that whole sentence the sentence
is letter C its most powerful
it says fastest most powerful Xbox so
that's where a lot of Sony people put
the heart in you know he put the tears
behind that gate it was just my thing
saying that my son will come
I want them tears in the bucket snatcher
they see filmin fills the dream
Shatterer I'm the tears not you
everybody
man I just woke up like 30 minutes ago
sleeping in all the way too much time
facts king of trying to lock people
outside the pearly girl the pearly gates
and stuff right now dudes is upset it's
gonna start here in about a couple
minutes so here in about a minute I'm
going to switch over to the actual
stream so right now last two minutes
we're gonna go through the panel real
quick yeah you're nave at the PS 5 is
stronger King is it strong forte is it
stronger death is it stronger Akeno is
it stronger
Lord Boxer dr elias is coming - coming
y'all be talking too much got out here
you're smack in the mouth as Lord will
is the color it's equal but it'll do
something different I don't think it's
stronger more efficiently and that'll
make up for all right now that's that's
basically him saying I want my PC to
still be the most powerful thing and I'd
rather well that we got it we got a
break we got a ball since the pandemic
pleased even as loathsome teraflop high
a check I can't hide their chat into the
video story it's a hot button on the
right until the video starts I can't do
full full screen that's fine we don't
see that we watching
[Music]
want to see micro round check when they
say eleven teraflops I do want to see
that chat crying I do still 11 tariff
laws I got the starting screen on
because I'm waiting for it to go to bed
ye 3 still be a relevant thing because
yo between they contact others they need
to stop he said to does so a check was
late
all right guys all right here we go
Bao's do it 1 minute and 48 seconds now
let me get this everyone stop talking I
got to get the volumes right
what the hell oh I told you to stop
talking all right now how does the sound
you guys it sound pretty because I want
to make sure it's balanced Oh slow mo
cinematic tell me to stop interrupting
slow mo being right once in a while
[Music]
brother come out with Bob Backlund roll
back are we louder than it definitely
louder turn them up what's loud in there
go bears someone someone mute and go
listen to it because I don't the chat
ain't clearly being entertained
we'd be some level adjustment let us
know how we sound in comparison to the
actual music he said HR Baba said we're
about to say it alright so I'll turn it
down just a hair okay probably do a
couple he said yeah he said a videos a
little what'd you say scream I'm sorry
oh no just yeah check the levels we're
about equal with the backside music I'm
seconds to become great some super
exciting news about PS 5 and who better
to bring that to you and the one and
only mark Cerny without further ado max
Annie
there will be lots of chance how'd this
dude wear that's right today I saw look
at that face
development of the console I think you
all know I'm a big believer in
consul-general
Oh once every five or six or seven years
a constant too low turn it up they say
in turn about I turned it on there's a
lot of learning by the game developers
hopefully not too overwhelming there's
games that could never have been created
before now it used to be that as a calm
voice is too low turn up the stream or I
turned the stream because oh the secrecy
this is my father's dude don't talk well
hurry had lasted through PlayStation 3
though I'm mark Sunni and I designed the
place also one that caused quite a lot
of heartache as it was initially
difficult to develop games build it in
complete secrecy for the PlayStation
consoles that period lasted through
PlayStation 3 a powerful and
groundbreaking console but also one that
caused quite a liking here someone
wasn't watching it in the background to
develop games for yes
starting with PlayStation 4 we've taken
a different approach roughly centered
around three principles the first of
these is listening to the developers
which is to say that a lot of what we
put into a console derives directly from
the needs and aspirations of the game
creators we definitely do have some look
like waves were a [ __ ] of our
philosophy designing console helo game
players are here for the fantastic games
which is to say that game creators
matter anything we can do to make life
help them real low audio games we will
do so about once every two years I take
a tour of the industry I go to the
various developers and publishers sit
down and discuss how they're doing with
the current consoles and what they like
I should turn it up but he's gonna make
you guys loud this requires weeks on the
road is reaching the bulk of the game
creators involves talking to well over a
hundred people it's something like two
dozen publishers very people that it is
incredibly valuable
don't they look fake by the way nobody's
a big fan of
we're very happy game developers the
youtubes of all to realize he's talking
on purpose at this point with the closed
captioning on the other hand that is the
hardware architect or handcuffed okay we
need to judge for each feature what
value it adds and whether it's worth the
increase in developer time needed to
support their so with PlayStation 4 we
were able to strike this is pretty
boring angle arts and familiarity we got
required learning back to PlayStation 1
levels the GPU was definitely the area
we felt the most tension between adding
new features and keeping a familiar
programming model ultimately I think
we've ended up with something under a
month of getting up to speed that feels
like we're striking about the right
balance I'll go into a bit less
officiator today about our what oh wow
it's also very important for us as the
host to find new dreams by which I know
something otherwise should I say if you
perform its GPU perform await send out
of RAM oh wait the increase in graphics
performance over the past two decades so
like a strong bob beckel in a
very much on our custom USB is
[Music]
shut up
this is king that copy on the top lift
that TV on the top that's just going to
the Xbox cuz this is boring
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
another strategy for increase the real
bar
why is he doing the CDC takedown like we
all develop nobody watches don't even
know night hours these PlayStation fans
will be making video later talk about
how porn if it Christopher Hart is
laughs yo by editing chief Jeff Ross
this is so far dreadfully boring box
poor
I mean the kids the kids makin noise is
more entertaining you said hi guys I'm
hello guys this is from Dreamcast guys
this is about to be a full hour
certainty whispering in my ear Bowser
solid-state drive zero gameplay good
info but I want to see back its
[Laughter]
[Music]
giving y'all exact numbers of the SSB
because it's not a four-tier fly we give
you less than a terabyte that's why we
[Music]
visit a flea the problem is at least you
can I feel that this was a reactor re
boy time and felt very reactionary so
here
this King is like I can't believe I get
is a bearable is a lot faster than a
series EXO allowed off the shelf
[Music]
you want to hear them are sure that the
argument you can't read for the
Wow Xbox is what they do video talking
about a controller no home on everybody
who did that for you we gotta do I gotta
do I go to the main scene and we got
their goals were roughly reduced power
to put data close that is bad
our DNA to microsoft says customer thr
with a BA marks on the ideas are
sufficiently specific
[Music]
I expect everyone taking the bed you
imagine how long it took to make this
video we're gonna base our flops against
our old flops all this
[Laughter]
in the console it's in if not as if
acosta cheating this unification
functionality running ps4 and PS 4
titles at boosted frequencies has also
added complexity the boost is truly
massiveness turnaround in some game
testing we recently took a look at the
true legislation for titles as ranked by
play time and we're expecting almost
almost this side even backwards
compatibility they do a node you
literally select items to new features
as I said our strategy was to try to
break new ground Oh so it's confirmed
only so almost all of them for more than
a day but you know Microsoft thing oh
you know even GE dedicated only song ps4
x not even fully back important the
fantasy star to online beta test starts
right now you wanna you wanna unlock the
rest of those on the back look at the
top 100 popular games and we got almost
all of them
[Laughter]
I'm about all it is risen he said [ __ ]
primitive worst part about this is he's
just going over stuff that Xbox has been
doing alright like look Microsoft was
like look first they don't want to hear
this nonsense let's give it to someone
that could say in a more entertaining
way here you go digital
Sony's like hold my beer so parties put
while the intersection engine is
processing the requested triangle it's a
good mix with logic now we're going for
different but yeah we doing different
phases of race we don't need to use race
it's a bit more of the GU invested in
rate racing it should be possible to do
some very nice global having said that
and reflections do traditional graphics
engine don't worry about it don't be
sleeping like GPU and what frequency do
we run it at this is a balancing act the
chip has a cost and there's a cost for
whatever we use to spy on gypsum
power that's cool for weed out women
though but actually the performance is
noticeably different because teraflops
is defined just you said to us or that
before well with the decider GC I think
that's the loudest way that's allowed
but that's the old Chester specters 33%
faster processing man when I was a pro
Coast that mean the l2 and the real
numbers up with it about the only
downside is that system memory is 33%
further away in terms of cycles large
number of more than caravans that as a
friend of a rising tide lifts all rapid
Memphis coming to lose thirty sixty use
in parallel than it is to fully use 48 I
feel like if you guys weren't here I'd
have to be like mystery take some
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
somebody had just I suspect my horizons
map scream with its low triangle count
makes my ps4 which it's no
the frequency of power what we use to do
is do it in the street yo I'm so glad
well what is today Wednesday Pacific
Power level in some ways it becomes a
simpler problem because there are
because I'm watching everyone's podcast
this baby by afternoon but you better
take your dad I say even flute God can't
help this presentation so I'd rather
listen to food guide this point strategy
the simplest approach would be to look
at the actual temperature of the silicon
die for them to admit to 3 gigahertz and
3.50 but not to reduce power it only
takes a couple of percent reduction in
10 point see if I was more I don't think
I don't think there's a way to get
around it there
like act like it didn't happen I mean
well right like they have anything those
are not real flops 13 no visuals are are
there is important but the impact has to
do a lot with a little
for example on PlayStation 4 there's no
what are you doing my man works audio
typically ends up getting just a
fraction of a fraud alert Wow my bad
what that was beautiful Wow doesn't say
you're like all right go work here and
freak what I'm gonna say two bits here
that's it meaning defeat there's a
marketing nothing conference which is
son enjoy yeah we'll be sitting still I
must mock things they haven't revealed
anything for just oh it's the VR the
okay okay
all I'm saying is I was just crying I
thought they would hold and this
provided a hint as to where we could go
with audio as well as some valuable
experience not to oversimplify was great
audio for everyone this whole damn
thanks been oversimplify would you mean
that no we're gonna DVR again the second
goal was to support the hundreds or you
for developers what sound
the stuff that I can say rain drops
locations this has the capacity to
affect your appreciation music gotta get
used to this new Sony indiscernible use
dead space I know ultimen they just said
Jacqueline speakers you could tell them
there was one last enemy growling and
hunt you down but it was difficult to
tell quite slow buh-ba-ba-bah Tracy full
range this makes it look good for that
foe hundred price point in what
direction the sound is coming from
sound waves bounce around inside the ear
power with it
[Music]
[Music]
tell me how kids smooth is going back
and finding everyone that said
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
why don't you put your box in PD man's
pose
you know it's crazy Sony's doing all the
[Laughter]
[Music]
work and therefore the algorithm can't
make fun xbox shows anymore after this I
get to say time GBC they should have
spice this up virtual surround sound
this was supposed to be the but since
it's not a they should have done this
better we have a amazing implementation
like if you look at the increasing the
size of that sweet spot at
let's get this over a show you a level
of transparency that you have never seen
with any company namely change the whole
narrative the owner I just have a
problem with this is you could closed
doors and put on an article and show
people why did you say we got to do this
you know what I think this is not
nothing I think they were they were
going to announce it and anyway I think
Microsoft knew they were going to do it
before normally wear stuff like know
ahead this is our day to do like boom
boys
so some ross album but yo legal what HRT
this is what I think Microsoft has a
leak over there and I think they were
going to surprise you all and say
tomorrow HRT s the PlayStation joint is
Mouse Microsoft know now remember did
you found you stuff that just came out
of no place my station file right that
was as well that was a no place and then
it would spread like wildfire we didn't
even know step down this is some of
these dudes that Redman research that
stuff was required when they can drop it
let me get back to the tutor to e3 Eric
Jason aren't the only ones being
homeschooled bad ps5 specs remote
sponsored by University of Phoenix
online
okay y'all can go alive now this is a
journal I'll be taking digital found you
didn't know that next day didn't say
that Brad Sam didn't know that all
everybody that didn't know nothing now
comes the fun part we get to see how the
development community takes advantage of
that feature set I'm hoping for the
completely unexpected will it come from
audio ray-tracing
the capabilities of the SS they better
have some treasure under this way I
guess don't find out soon enough
thank you set me loose
and and for anybody that thought job was
coming from my knees my knees secure
Bonnie Abbate Wow
all right so we're in the post show man
we back your Google Hangouts King how'd
you like that he was straight garbage
you know what mark sighing I want my
money back again but I told you when
they do kill look me in my eye
I don't trust him I seen him make sure
he ran out the room so I understand
exactly what we're dealing with yeah
I'll be careful man
watch out now to the 2006 tart
collecting knees listen if y'all want
somebody that y'all could get behind
pull get my heart oh man that ain't the
PC dudes looked over said ten teraflops
[Music]
out out the boom he was a hundred
situation there is show nothing at all I
said that first I'm gonna start giving
anybody credit I told you what they were
gonna do this will come out with the dry
mouth and mark was gonna do what he was
gonna do I put my wax out early so we
did here we did Christopher you back you
alive we did see the system we didn't we
didn't get a price so nothing you saw
nothing I told you mark Simon II was
gonna say
less than nothing and more nothing
nothing you got nothing showed you
nothing gave you nothing
you walk away with everything so what
did you have to give up everything got
robbed did you notice how like actually
they were being with that SSD they spent
probably 25 to 30 minutes just on that
SSD I would say like I said I was
surprised that they even talked about
the de teraflops I thought I was so
surprised at this point I don't think it
comes the la carte
it comes the la carte and that's that's
it I think at this point they had it
they'd had no choice there to I mean
they know how to fine-tune the hard core
community is with these teraflops that
say not saying it would have been
probably just what I'd stock it went
down baby 2.4 percent down mmm see you
see it you see it it's just disgusting
is looking disgusting out here since
Marc started talking soon as Marc open
his mouth stock started falling this is
fantastic
so they apparently just horizon zero
dawn on PC won't ship with an F of V
slider to avoid compromising the
original experience I don't even know
what that means but people on PC are
definitely speaking about sure oh yeah
cheeto your neck he said Microsoft down
almost father said to King the world
mm-hmm
yo Joe down flops what about those flops
go
get to those flop she thought she was to
come out with the big chances no we Bob
Backlund's you got your back okay stadia
got what teraflop new Playstation ok
edges that lovely show keep it up all
love from well listen y'all this was
yeah this is definitely dry this was not
what we expected exactly what I knew was
gonna happen exactly what I knew was not
happening
I had no fair yeah you ever knew he's
gonna win a fight he was gonna go
outside you go when you you sort of
bullies like I see [ __ ] in his arm I'm
and knock him out the day see that's
that tall so you knew you gonna win so I
came out dressed impressed I hope y'all
impressed by what I hope y'all wasn't
impressed with journey and in are
impressed with this shiny gotta fight
out a super chat they rush to get the
bad news out because it just came out
later after them being silent for so
long PlayStation fan boys would have
been deserting PlayStation right unless
I see people on Twitter are already
saying that they're going on Xbox
because the backwards compatibility is
already can only give me 35 games from
the rip a lot of people know a lot of
people thought that they were going to
UM what's up fullback I bet they and
they're gonna fall backwards
compatibility in the box we already know
who we got on our team we got the
leading minds in that field but you know
what you got you already know what's
there regardless if that was the GD
summary man I think they could have
ended that with a trailer because it
wasn't GDC like yeah it's like look this
is all the boy stuff we already did that
before GDC we're gonna have to do it
anyway
but here's what it can look like once
the game is being arranged all I want to
ask you is this who Sony is this who's
man's is this and you know what suni is
this is any Sony that you ever seen I've
never seen these before this is the fake
sorry this is the Saudi that Saudi
should have been this is Jimmy stop that
stop it
they get it I'm wit Shah
all I'm saying is it is a GD I don't
like that button you try to throw it
here I'll see what they do the stream
you saw look the one thing that my whole
problem with this one stream is the fact
that Microsoft did something that I
think is palatable to the type of
information you're giving out you need
to put that information in a blog post
or you hand it over to people that are
it they're capable entertaining enough
to talk about
he took literally the same information
they just gave us and spices it up and
made it look good like he did a better
job explaining SSD in that twenty five
to thirty minute video than they did in
30 minutes like facts but magic is what
what about this would say what about
let's just say like they already had
that pre-recorded and as you saw
religious just get it out let's just get
it out so at that point when the moment
GBC was canceled the moment GBC was
cancelled that should have been
cancelled they should because they're
going from exploit like showing them to
a crowd that cares just showing that to
a crowd that doesn't care and they
didn't really go into much detail when
they made the announcement they're just
like let's let's just show people all
the developers gonna take advantage just
this pad out this meaty smell with the
two dollar super chair lucky this wasn't
the Apollo daggone short they were the
guys really got booed offstage I ain't
go by the Sandman because the Sandman is
out there putting this to sleep the
biggest thing is once you transition
from a crowd at GDC like even like most
of us still want to watch this reveal at
GDC and probably would have still been
bored as hell but at least we would have
known that the backdrop of what its
gonna be talked about is for the
developers it's being done at GDC
run you once you break that away and
take GDC away from it the whole story
you should have changed it should have
been a completely different presentation
right and and maybe it should have just
been like I said a block
oles information to people that are able
to communicate that same information
through Microsoft just ready for some
more knowledge ah um Forte do you think
um that there's something really going
on that they don't want to put it in the
hands of a lot of these tech guys just
give it to him and let them do they
thing with it because what I saw what
Microsoft coz the first time we saw the
directly Xbox one X right yeah and we
was astounded by the fact that you know
Microsoft gave it over to digital
foundry and say you do your thing you
know um and I'm pretty sure there was
some caveat you can't do this I can't do
that or whatever but very minimum this
time I think there was no railings put
on when they gave them the series X cuz
they gave it to him in pieces and told
him to put it together they show demos
of certain things current gen games wit
ray-tracing
on and told them you know listen do you
spell how you're going to do it and they
gave it to multiple different tech guys
so you wasn't just getting one narrative
feeling that you were steered in one
direction they aint they gave it to
numerous dudes and just left the
information out there and on their page
they just put out a fact sheet so it was
no Microsoft efficient stuff it's just a
fact sheet no videos from them and they
did that box on later after everybody
else stuff came out this is some type of
concern here this is some type of alarm
here that one we don't see no silicon no
visual silicon we don't see a form
factor we only see a controller and we
don't I mean we saw dev kits but I mean
what what's going on because usually at
this point in time we're going to see
some type of form factor lease and I
mean they've been talking about the SSD
for over a year now this didn't we gotta
get yeah we got Disney the father of
Sony was not gonna be at GDC in the
first place stop give him a slot but
Pratt says this was for developers no
different than when they reveal ps4
playstation 4 Pro don't worry
well I'm not I'm gonna tell braaap this
I'm telling you this all you just trying
to do is keep your PlayStation I mean
your PC hot and tack you already know
that the exes is already on your neck so
he just thought that you're gonna be
boxed in from the PlayStation annex no
just the X needs to box you down that's
it boy you already know the X is more
powerful than your PC that you just got
for like twenty thousand dollars you pay
20 grand on your joint right there
an Xbox just came out with a joint that
smashed your joint so we know where you
will hold up Brad rattling breath you
are more welcome to coming to eiope this
Sunday in defense your planchette what's
the difference what a difference a day
makes yesterday all these crazy fanboy
just give us your opinion on this real
quick before we address who currently
live doing a reaction to the xbox of the
real show but bro like I completely miss
right this is what happened right mm-hmm
I started to watch it I didn't
understand what was going on because I
felt like Alexa was talking to me for
just too long and I just happened to
look at my phone and it looks like
Eurogamer had all this bad yeah so I
read then was seeing when the stream is
just didn't mean anything to me and I'm
sitting here I spent the entire hour
argue with people on Twitter and I
realize I look back at my second mine I
realize the screen was black and a
stream was over I'm like kid commit you
missed the greatest part of the whole
thing when he said thank you thank you
for showing up you're not getting
anything I told you we'll see you let's
have everything amore nothing so we
actually see something because obviously
this was not it's hard to tell at this
point man they got to get his work on
Twitter man you know what the funniest
thing about this whole thing is that we
were saying before you came in here that
Microsoft took the exact same thing they
just did
but they gave it to other people to make
it more interesting yeah
yes the most important thing to have in
there like Austin take this digital
foundry take this take the knowledge you
know on how you've been explaining tech
to people who don't know tech and
explain our tech to them yeah developers
that's not the grandma there's a lot of
people talking reckless said it
definitely will be more powerful next
Bucks Fizz y'all go get this work that
were talking too much
it's what did I tell you last night we
were directly added me yesterday he made
he made a new account yesterday he at me
yesterday say about it is I told you why
it's not called me because he was like I
don't know that dude got that writers
like at the end of the day delegate
people the the numbers to fake stuff
like that when you have someone like
Dillard that you know has been right on
a lot of these kinds of performance
rights you could take his numbers
because they're not official they're not
confirmed and just deal early Xbox with
the $2 check I'm being Petty and messy
they need these hands all I've said is
the big mystery was there teraflops and
based on their history in the past of
being petty the old Sony that was also
removed with a bit like oh well you did
this you showed everything whether that
was the narrative the narrative right
there
we got JB Dima for the final super don't
we miss him yeah yeah yeah I don't care
this was for the dares on me
this was god-awful now I want those
PlayStation fans to keep the same energy
and take them else Xbox always energy
was like yo Oh Sony oh wow yeah showed
your hand that was the narrative right
all right xbox showed their hand too
early and this too a lot of Sony fan
base was the clap back so in that
respect yes it's out is this though
getting around that you know we're about
to end this because I got I got to get
ready for work and stuff but no before
we end this I want to go through this
panel and tell me yay or nay what did
you presentation I know you you secret
lives over there like in that man I know
you were you was like no words oh my god
I got I got this DC pass what did you
think man it was no no no it was this
string was for this would have been a
good stream if it was at GDC but once it
once it got canceled this stream should
have got canceled it should have been
something completely different and I
just know I can't get the last hour back
of my time that I just dizzy everyone in
the chat asked to be in here but kid
Smith I invited kids you didn't ask
you literally could have said yo get me
an invite I would have sent you one but
we're gonna we're gonna move on with
this death what did you brat hold on we
go they can wait till after we go
through every one death how did you fit
yeah oh sorry I just woke up yeah I'll
just say it was a year presentation
there we go speechless on a presentation
yeah
it's a neigh-neigh like I said I stopped
paying a twist into it like ten minutes
in what's wrong
III don't want to ask called me you know
cuz he own that like round one scream
did that convince you to buy PlayStation
did you hear they have an SSD no no it's
not what I asked you
I play station later can't see us see
this tweet right now no exactly
I'm gonna say that presentation was
pretty much exactly what I expected from
ps4 they were gonna go into some very
specific angles of things that they do
differently yes disregard what they yeah
are worse but go into like just try to
be way overly specific on some my knee
ass yeah most people probably don't even
think about and including Microsoft but
there was there was no way that they
were gonna walk in I had no idea I never
thought that they were gonna walk into
this really with more like power I mean
like this is no way they they can't
compete with Microsoft at this point so
let's go ahead and get these super chat
and get everyone out of here
so we got a $2.00 super chair from
Superman how does Sony spit almost 30
minutes talking about audio
anyone got any comment on that because
literally they spent 30 minutes talking
about just about everything they they
had a diagram to help internet works
okay look this this this isn't something
this is something that I already knew
what probably happened because the two
things they talked about the most
was a spatial audio and your SSD yeah
though those are the two things that
everybody knew was a key component of
the playstation 5 and all they did was
double down on that stuff in like and
like we'll just said they're they're
gonna talk about everything that they do
will and ignore everything they know
they can't compete in it and that's
pretty much everything with pops up
Forte they're surprised what you gonna
do was no controller they is they've
waited so long and there's been so much
hype and pretty much everyone knew at
this point so then they had like if they
will not have said that people would
have attacked for being far no one knew
for sure the rumors were that remember
the room is I just think it was the
problem let me talk to him do you think
that's being arrogant but they're like
we don't care we'll show you the numbers
we don't care I think it's a it's a it's
a mentality shift it's a philosophy
shift because to me the old Sony right
that that is a little more or less a
arrogant aggressive right like they are
not going to put themselves in any bear
life to me by putting 10 parents on a
machine when you're your competitors
just the other day said twelve and all
this other stuff was doing I'm shocked I
was surprised they with on guarding him
he'll play to is coming for their head
then we got a $5 super chap from bright
excited to see what Naughty Dog and
others so any first party do with PS 5
hardware I mean and you know everyone's
excited for the games Brad but you still
go get this l like this this
presentation was bad but anyway you got
a $2.00 super chaps mini Smith to be
fair mark Cerny had a nice suit a suit
you know that I was born after four say
that finish up yeah so for me the reason
I think this is something that they the
reason I'm not surprised I gave that
number is because at this point like I
said when Microsoft's did there
bill yesterday is at this point if you
are weaker pull the band-aid off now
ripping off because if you don't rip it
off now you're gonna allow that
narrative to seep through the rest of
the gear into the game for the system
what about you keep the mystery if no so
you got Final Fantasy you got call it
you got the lost last of us to coming
out you think you also have ghost Ashima
coming out in big it like end you gotta
make people forget so what what by that
by the time those games start launching
the thing that's gonna matter the most
is the games so just rip the band-aid
off now because my main happens people
ain't gonna be caring about let that be
a conversation last dude a horse games
I'm here for gaming 14 the and the 10.2
teraflops
and then we got that little peel he said
long as PlayStation 4 is pumping games
it'll be a rough start for PlayStation 5
in the beginning I don't know but it
again III here where you're going for -
it's just again I I'm not used to this
Saudi that's all I'm saying this is that
I would expect from them I would expect
from a marketing perspective you never
show what you're weaker to your
competitor you you hold that I remember
even with the PlayStation 4 Pro remember
they would do little marketing things
did not let you know that the X was the
more powerful system they would say
little specific buzzwords and focus on
what they did they did that for the most
part but when they do the 10 up I was
surprised I was like oh that's kind of
like you admitting defeat on that part
what just I mean it's honest you know
I'm saying we know that we knew they
were it was just surprising that's one
but all in all it was a bad luck you
know I I did not like it at all um yes I
understand it's GDC yes I understand
it's for that crowd but at the end of
the day for them to be this quiet for so
long and this the finally time first
time we see them on stage on any
capacity for a while this is this was
very disappointing I'm not I'm not
trying to excuse it so just gotta see
how they boss back difficult going in
this you're appreciate everyone coming
through definitely hit that like button
there you know we're about to go up but
act
we leave definitely go there and gifts
kits boots of support yes he and there
he's in his bag right now I've been
looking at history if he he's had to
happen but I don't do not miss ILP this
week you guys do not receipt season
we're going to we out peace please